- [Voiceover] Welcome to the Khan Academy.
The goal of this video is to show you
all the different things
that Khan Academy has.
It has videos, it has exercises,
it has an adaptive,
super, I guess you could
call it robot tutor
thing that will guide you
through content and
make sure you master it.
So let's just take each
of those one by one.
Many of y'all are probably
coming to this saying,
"Hey, I have an exam tomorrow on DNA," or
"I didn't understand quite
what's happening in class."
There the best thing to do might just be
go to the search bar,
let me make sure you can
see the search bar, to
go to the search bar
and you could search for DNA.
When you do that you see your first choice
right over is a DNA video.
This is actually the main video on DNA
and which you could start watching.
Or if you look to the
right right over here,
you see that there's
all other related videos
under heredity and genetics.
Then you can start browsing from there.
You could say, "Okay,
let me back up a second.
"Let me go back to just all of biology."
I can see all of the sections are there.
Similarly, you might wanna search
for something in mathematics.
You might wanna say,
"Oh, I have a question
"about quadratics."
Quadratics.
I'm gonna do a search there.
Okay, well let's see, there's something
about using the quadratic formula,
factoring quadratics 2.
I don't know which of
these is right for me,
so let me just go into one of these
and start getting a little bit of context.
You see that what I
actually just clicked on
is actually an exercise that gets me
to solve quadratics by factoring two.
I need to write my answer here.
If I don't know the answer,
I have a bunch of hints.
If this all looks like Greek to me,
I can click on a video
that solves a very similar problem.
Or I might hey, this isn't
what I was looking for.
But look over here, they're solving
a quadratic equation by factoring.
Factoring quadratic equations.
Maybe this is what I need to learn.
Or maybe I'm not even
thinking about this stuff,
so let me just move up a level
to quadratic equations.
Now I can see the whole topic here.
Solving quadratics by taking square root.
Solving quadratics by factoring.
Completing the square,
the quadratic formula.
Quadratic equation, graphing quadratics.
In general if you just wanna browse,
you say "Let me just see all the subjects
"that are available on Khan Academy."
You can go this drop-down right over here.
This starts to give you
a sense of the breadth
of the content on Khan Academy.
Just in math, each of
these is an entire subject.
K-2nd math, you have pre-calculus,
goes all the way up to
multivariable calculus,
intergal calculus.
If I were to click on
any one of these things,
it's going to take me into
something called a mission.
A mission is going to give
me a set of exercises.
We call this right over
here the mission warm-up.
Based on how I perform on
these calculus questions,
the system is starting to get a sense
of what I know and don't
know and it will use that
to give me guided practice
so I can learn more
and more and more calculus.
Eventually mastering calculus.
At any point if I have difficulty,
there's always videos
here that will help me
understand the actual calculus.
Once I'm done with that, I
will go to this dashboard
and it'll just tell me
about how much have I
progressed in integral
calculus, what have I mastered,
what have I not practiced yet,
what are my different badges.
If you do not wanna move immediately
into this mission world and you wanna say
what does Khan Academy have when it comes
to calculus in an unguided way,
that's where you go view full list
of integral calculus content.
Then you will go to this page,
where you see the breadth and scope
of the integral content.
Integrals, integration techniques,
integration applications,
sequences and series,
AP calculus practice problems.
If you click there, you see the different
tutorials within, indefinite integrals
as anti-derivative, area
under a rate function
as net change.
Hopefully that gives you sense of things.
We don't just have math and we don't just
have science, we have whole section here
on computer programming,
which is tons of fun
where you can write your
own computer program.
I'm using my son's account right now.
This is a computer program that we wrote.
This right here is a computer program
that we wrote together the other day.
It was good father/son bonding time.
And we have things in
the arts and humanities,
like history and art history,
which is also very, very, very exciting.
And we have partner content.
We have partner content from the likes of
The Museum of Modern Art, Explortorium,
JP Getty Museum, The British Museums.
So a lot of stuff here.
Hopefully this video gives you a flavor
of the different ways
you can use Khan Academy.